[Rires]
toujours pas de zéro à deux mois
[Musique]
deux mois et demi
aujourd'hui la télévision est venu nous
voir pour constater l'état du désespoir
à 13,3 ma présence au canada
oui oui parce que vous aimeriez lui être
dans une ressource ou rester ici non ne
refuse pour itinérants pour être pas du
tout j'ai en effet plusieurs j'ai tout
cas pas de la merde pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont aux dictateurs ils sont
libres ici
ici tout est lié c'est ça j'avais
qu'elle a aujourd'hui 21 qui est ce que
tu as cherché à mener un appartement
j'essayais gouverner c'est que j'ai un
chien un pitbull s'est fait que ces
programmes 1 mais c'est de trouver un
acheteur sans doute à l'âge mais kpatcha
pillon qui est l'âge importe où tu en es
dans ton parcours de vie globale masque
les études commencées difficile après tu
cherches plusieurs variables ou via
notte tu peux aller
quand on a des cloportes plupart des
maîtrise des méthodes et des abris ou
secours elle a également dit voudrait
que j'ai l'argent aussi pour pouvoir
tourner aux études ou si leurs deux oui
un accès gratuit mais c'est pour adapter
dans le plu pour tout le monde puis à
trois points de consommation qui vient
compliquer tout seul ouais mais c'est
dur en même temps de s'enligner pour un
travail ou de l'étude peu importe leur
ont parlé de l'étude quatre appareils la
consommation le cercle vicieux
exactement
comment t'est arrivé si crise du
logement aides sociales puis moment je
te peu désillusionnés puis-je tango
j'aime pas travailler quand je commence
à avoir une routine travaillé 40 ans
jamais on dirait que je deviens triste
d'un coup que la vitrine s'installent
puissent des quand je deviens trio je
deviens mélancolie que ça dure jamais
longtemps
c'est parfait pour moi ce genre de
vidéos gens je demande à vous deux
je reviens je reviens mettant au début
décembre y arrive quoi vous êtes tout
est plutôt vide que je vous souhaite un
bon café et puis on a ri salut montréal
comment vous êtes arrivé ici le mode
histoire pourquoi une longue histoire
c'est je devais des événements ah ouais
il fallait que je pense que nous ruine
ça m'était j'aimerais écrire soviétique
le moment présent ça fait quand même
votre affaire le parquet sur seiche
samsung samsung de bedie bonne chance
viendrait me raconter ça dans un an ça
lui oui merci tout des dons à hiesse
comment vous avez abouti ici
ben moi je fais de la compagnie en
externe
j'ai particules qui adore d'avant le des
années qui sait de l'accompagnement
alors qu'à quelqu'un sait pourquoi faire
tout ça pour aller où lyon géologie des
pêcheurs de nourriture à faire ce que je
fais mais c'est le jeu et la question
mais vous dormez bord aussi de bouloc
comment vous voyez le dilemme des
prochaines semaines la mairesse
on n'en verra pas la police évidemment
mais on voudrait qu'ils partent comment
voyez ce que je pense je divague
profanateurs le froid qui m'ont tendu
monte à des chaleurs devront trancher
d'ivoire est au complet
au nord il y en a donc c'est des
problèmes de santé mentale
des preuves des problèmes de
consommation ce sont également des deux
sites contractuels à consommer et à
temps secrètement tout le monde était
respectueux il quand quelque chose qui
fait à pau où il ya quelqu'un qui
déplaît fait un mauvais geste déplacé ou
notre coin et explicite quand on demande
à partir on ne veut pas de problème
c'est arrivé oui c'est encore une fois
on demandait aux gars de party parce
qu'elle gagne et il est agressif claque
et on a des gars c'est pas ta place
on veut pas de problème en leur nom des
voisins fabien sa voix bien que tu viens
de nous voir avec la pratique afrique
nous on était on est capable de changer
le monde on est déjà écrivain normal
j'ai senti la fierté on ne parlait
plusieurs personnes fierté aussi de
cette organisée ouais bah je sais pas ce
que je sais faire
j'ai fait c'est spontané que qu'est-ce
qui est aigri le tout les temps sont
bien s'installer tout l'accueil est là
on est rendu comme un petit répit c'est
quoi votre histoire de vie
est arrivé
je connais tu n'as de l'ong qui manie de
séparation que je souhaitais être avez
vous des preuves de consommation wii et
gamecube
sinon comment vous voyez ou dans un mois
et demi j'attends d'y jouer
winch on est capable de viser les louer
une chambre sylvain bonleux partait au
début le répartir la charge
de partie h f pour vous et
personnellement je veux dire une chose
en train de tenir tête au bout
di maria
[Musique]
7e vie
m
[Musique]
mais ajoute m et
quoi que tu fasses
m
[Musique]